au fil de l'eau là tout accompagné par
deux autres embarcations glisse sur la
loire comme il ya cinq siècles ou
presque
trois équipages ont été constitués pour
mener à bon port
la précieuse cargaison un bloc de
tuffeau 60 à 80 kg à hauteur de
montlouis-sur-loire 1 du saut le convoi
parti de tours doit couper le moteur
pour éviter les bancs de sable
c'est à bras d'homme que l'embarcation
est tiré
les difficultés c'est qu'effectivement
la loire est extrêmement basse en plus
cet été un été particulièrement sec
donc il ya très peu d'eau les points etc
seront difficiles ce sont les passages
le pont il s'agit plus de sortir les
moteurs ni même les bourdes il va
falloir y aller ou à l'âge avec des
système de palan et c'est pour ça qu'on
est une petite équipe quand même pour
pouvoir voilà faire voilà faire appel
aux sommiers scotto de chacun baptisé le
voyage de la pierre tout est parti d'un
rêve devenu réalité une réalité chargée
de symboles
nous avons décidé de retracer le
parcours historique des pierres entre
tours et saint dié sur loire tel qu'on
l'a fait il ya 500 ans pour les livrer
sur le chantier de chambord ensuite
cette pierre de tuffeau elles
représentent toutes les autres elle
représente les bâtisseurs de chambord
elles représentent tous ceux qui
travaillent pour le château tous ceux
qui l'aiment
donc elle a une forte valeur et c'est
pour ça aussi que ce n'est pas une
simple pierre que l'on transporte
on va ensuite si nous obtenons
l'autorisation l'installer dans les murs
du château à l'emplacement d'une pierre
n'ont pas d'origine mais une pierre
ancien pas très en forme et en même
temps on a voulu que cette pierre soit
une capsule temporelle donc vous verrez
et qu' il y a un petit fils noirs sur le
dessus qui permettra de soulever un
couvercle et à l'intérieur dans l'espace
libre nous déposerons des petits objets
mystère mystère encore trois jours de
navigation à raison de 30 à 40 km par
jour avant saddier sur loire la
destination finale